the selling of second-hand books along
the river sane dates back nearly 500
years the iconic green box stalls have
held UNESCO world heritage status since
1991 but most of them will need to move
for security reasons next year to make
way for the unique opening of the Paris
2024 Olympics the first ever ceremony to
be held outside a stadium and free to
the public 600 000 people are expected
to watch as athletes and delegations
sail along the river
there will be a party in Paris and we're
joyous for this party but we feel like
the booksellers are unwanted and they
want to exclude us from the party
today there are 900 green stalls
stretching three kilometers through the
center of Paris making it the largest
open-air book Market in Europe
the same was once described as the only
river in the world that stretches
between two bookshelves
we are a major symbol of Paris tourists
come to see us as they do for the Eiffel
Tower the Louvre or Notre Dame we are
raising and rejecting this major symbol
it's as if we're disassembling the
Eiffel Tower because it's too tall to
fit inside the frame
the booksellers known as the buchanists
have been offered a spot nearby in a
so-called Bookseller Village for the
duration of the games and authorities
say they'll be compensated for the
relocation cost and any damage caused
look at the condition of this container
this container is at least 100 years old
if it's moved this container would not
survive that operation nor will the
morale of the booksellers
some local residents and tourists share
the concerns of the booksellers I don't
know why they will be doing this because
it's part of the Paris experience
so many things for security reasons but
sometimes it's unnecessary in my opinion
Paris is more important than one event
that is completely temporary
the Olympics is less than a year away
now but will only last two weeks whereas
after half a millennium the tradition of
selling books on the banks are the same
will No Doubt last for a lot longer than
that David Stokes Al Jazeera